далі частину села вона вся там дозвольте
на 40 парафій був
вчора
утера реактивна артилерія танки
стріляють які стріляють
гармати
я сам як не кадровий офіцер військовий я в
свого часу навчався в університеті
закінчив військову кафедру outcry нам вже
технолог я головний інженер
підприємства машина буде багато
підприємствами стружки до їх 3
травня фронт на донеччині shemale ними
сценах жителі дружківка бахмут ata raid
худоби та всіх місць на донбасі немає ніхто
знає ще нас правдина суть за haste to
звіриними ауру заміни путіна
про beatniks краматорська олексій дібцева
татом пишеш дня пишу на війну
добровольцем
просто рідний weak to інвалідність у
перервах між обстрілами потаскун алія
свою українську тут змінила в
онлайнових
це розгуляєшся вже хамд це та їх
виживаєш тисніть повз мою практику
путін теж
не ніхто там не що таке навіть не
думаючи там йшов путін квестом захищає
таких не таких людей або mac і ну я не
зустрічав допустимі в краматорську в той час
нікого не
змучені за чоловіка ми лише ніхто не
прям вже і ваш теж розум кут susie q
вона крім типу скаржачись таки піди цей
rubbage ну якщо ти в українській армії то
ти можеш бути російською за принципом
моя позиція
ну прийшов українською
українську а за професію
токаря літра тільки розширити їх ми по
трапу етики чому всі 27 числа я відразу
того ж дня я поїхав диском від її чоловік і
прийняті навчальна травма 3 інвалід провини
так би мовити вона третя група то вона я
прийшов у душу ну
давайте начистоту воювала так
ну їжі крутіше де від нас там rotten
візьму шматок
ну і нашу але така самі сидить і доньок
відібрати у пологи пройдуть і там зараз
будуть у розумі це цінується ураган
відсікає будинки вийдуть на
котячим умову та славу та y за долар
олександр стружки в ктс доброволець вбрання
мине алексія ризикового досвіду move
у team мотивації до зайвого фермера не
шлюбу та
п'ятнадцятому уроці я прямо до скроні
мобілізації
uleyskaya не потрапив тому здоров'я.
ну і скажу я які трахи було особисто жити
хочеться шкіри не любимо
потім я навпроти і всіх цих рокер
є посмішок наші українці
миколаїв я трохи бо людина
гинути
на важливого молодіє трохи собою коли
молоді хлопці
посунути кожного дня міні було бік
отрути висока людина захочеться будинок і я
завжди всім пробачив кого їй надали
всі
закінчу потребу на стану я йду на
вологодчині ніч
24 лютого
брат і російська
ви наважилася наказувати
25 лютого я поїхав ризиком від якщо вас
назвуть є чимось ми наїдемо зростання
коріння мої предки з польських євреїв
чия україна тут на porsche та черні
алаві своїм корінням оновлюватися на кону
все біля путіна стрибнув і одразу не чого
україни з єврея ще на донбасі і вас
любимо і подивимося
я живу на свої землі імені путін взагалі
не указ абсолютно і ми тут зовсім лінії
вій росіянам і ніколи допомагали
потреба викликала новачок жити ж
вигляд волі і свободи стане я терпець це
якщо скажемо у міс сам скажу так як
думаю я можу почистити хлопці wicked
арматуру як із бровою тайці вели не так
вже якщо всі талих а то вона нам принесла
прямого їм будь вона може у нас їжі на
шлях захисту
Путінці так як нам означає цю імперію
косичку вона дасть нам скільки у прямого
на для чорних крилами кумир путіна
Адольф Гітлер
the wind по життю скривджений деки мета
дурник